I now like to begin looking at how you're going to deal with, you, and
you'll know, relationships that show up in your analysis model.
In your ultimate program, there aren't any, direct representations of those,
particular relationships, so during design you need to
come up with a strategy for how you're going to deal with them. First one we
like to look at is generalization. Now, object oriented programming languages
have a feature called inheritance, and I want to take a minute to describe to
you the differences between inheritance and generalization, because it can
get you into trouble if you just routinely treat one as the same as the other.
First off, Generalization is an abstraction between two classes that mean that
all instances of the child class are also instances of the parent class.
Inheritance, on the other hand, is an implementation technique, whereby messages
sent to a child may be delegated to a parent. You can use inheritance to,
implement Generalization, but you have to be careful how you do it.